but what about you like you've got a
white mum and you believe that all white
people are inherent so your mum is
inherently racist
I mean I I can tell you I didn't look
into these ideas too deeply
uh which is why they fell apart whenever
I was pressed on them I think I would
have found a way to blame it on the
people who I disagree with you
I really think I would have managed I
was really good at just running my mouth
and twisting words if you look into
leftism and you look into it deeply and
especially identity politics you will
find that there is no space to be
whoever it is that you want to be there
is no space to think whatever it is that
you want to think and in fact they are
hell-bent on pushing people into boxes I
felt no greater racism than going on the
internet and saying I am a conservative
it was unbelievable how quickly people
jumped to me and said well you're a
female You couldn't possibly be a
conservative you're half black You
couldn't possibly be conservative this
is the box that is created for those
identity markers and we must Jam you
into that box and if you do not fit you
are alienated you are no longer a part
of the club if you want to really
experience or get as close to the Jim
Crow experience as possible be a black
person that comes out as a conservative
and it will you will you will experience
it
foreign
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
guest today is a fellow YouTuber Amalia
pinobi welcome to trigonometry it's good
to be here guys it's great to have you
on I've been trying to do this for a
while it didn't happen that then
happened now we're here anyway it's
great to have you on the show uh thanks
for coming on uh before we get into the
conversation itself we always ask our
guests what is your story how did you
get here uh you you've had a quite an
interesting story even though you're
very young so tell everybody what that's
been like
sure yeah so I'm Amala I'm 22 years old
and I'm currently working as a podcaster
and social media content maker for
prageru and talking about conservative
or at least right-of-center values on a
daily basis and I got here by virtue of
actually being a reformed woke leftist I
grew up in a very small town in rural
conservative Florida and happened to be
raised by a single mother who is a
leftist herself and works for the
political left so growing up with her
and with her influence I was really
deeply entrenched in woke ideology and
thought that the best case of action
that I should pursue in my life was to
be an activist so I graduated high
school started working for the very same
organization that my mother was at as a
youth organizer so essentially going
around and finding other young people
who are maybe disillusioned with the
state of America and drawing them down
the pipeline of of wokism and I did that
for about a year before realizing this
is not the ideology for me I was finding
a lot of hypocrisy I was feeling that a
lot of the things that I was doing were
a bit too radical and ended up leaving
that organization sort of searching for
where I laid politically and that ended
up being right of Center
and eventually I just started making
videos about that transformation
transformation in my life in that period
and it brought me to where I am now so
and one of the interesting things that I
read in terms of the research is uh
while you have moved from the left to
being right of Center you also went we
saw this where both uh you and us and a
bunch of other people were the Matt
Walsh incident where you're quite happy
to push back against people who you
think are going too far on your own side
as well so uh is is that because you've
seen what radical Nest does whichever
side of the political Spectrum it's on
yes it's it's definitely partially that
and it's also that having been a woke
leftist and having changed my mind I
have a good idea for for what works and
I've tested it and going around to
different universities and talking to
students who really disagree with
everything it is that I stand for and
that I have to say and I found that the
best course of action for talking to
those sorts of people is a trying to
understand where they're coming from and
B not really indulging in those ad
hominem attacks that we sometimes want
to throw out at people and trying to
Usher them over to the other end of the
Spectrum by just giving them facts and
trying to meet them where they're at and
I felt with the with the Matt Walsh
video much like you both did that
something needed to be set because I
didn't want that to be a representation
of where we are in the fight against
gender ideology
and you're very young for someone to be
to be on the other side of the political
Spectrum normally it happens in their
30s and their 40s when they start to
earn a bit of money and they go hang on
a second right so what was the moment
for you what was your red pill moment
let's just call it that
sure there were many I I say this a lot
there was no specific light bulb moment
that really flipped things over for me
it was gradual meeting of just
roadblocks when it came to what I was
trying to support and I tried so
desperately to hold on to my
left-leaning ideology because I had
staked so much of my life on it and so
much of my identity on it I even have a
black power fist that's tattooed on my
arm here that people can see in my other
videos and I got that yeah
yeah I got that when I was 16 years old
thinking you know what it's brilliant
let me brand myself with this sort of
pseudo-religious symbol because I'm
never going to deviate from from this
sort of thinking but if I could hone in
on one moment in particular when I was
working for this organization we would
come together and have meetings and
before every meeting we do community
agreements which are basically rules
that everybody abides by throughout the
duration of the conversation so things
like State your pronouns before you
speak for the first time or if you know
someone has a story that is particularly
oppressive and sad let them speak the
whole way through no interrupting and I
had a co-worker come up and at the end
of her community agreements essentially
say that all the white cisgendered
heterosexual people in the room just
shouldn't speak at all during this
meeting it just wasn't their time they
had their time in history and being
biracial I was raised by the white side
of my family so I sort of looked around
this room people who were nodding in
agreement and thinking that was the
right thing to do and I just had this
little thought that was like amla you're
you're in the wrong room I think
you're in the wrong room and just ended
up exploring that further and now here
we are
do you think part of the problem with
the left is that is if they stuck to the
idea of look Society is unequal there's
rich and there's poor there's an Ever
widening gap between the two this is
clearly unfair we need to do something
to make Society fairer economically you
might not have had that moment and other
people might not
yeah I I think had they stuck to
some of the earlier tenets of their
ideology we would be just really in a
better place as a society it seems as
though when we look at I guess left
versus right if we won't even put it
that simply today they've sort of
crossed over each other in in a lot of
different ways the left used to be super
pro skepticism they were pushing Pro
equality they were anti-establishment
and those were the tenets that people
really grasped onto and I think that's a
an amount of progressivism that every
society needs progressivism is always
welcome and it's necessary to move
forward as a pluralistic society but
they sort of just changed and shift and
morphed into something that is
completely deviated from what were the
original tenets and that's why a lot of
people have problems and they're
switching I think like all of us right
now having this conversation maybe we do
have liberal leanings in us I think
everybody does but what they've become
now is just so far from from liberal
well let's talk about that because uh
you are right of Center Francis and I
didn't even go as far as that I don't
think we're kind of somewhere in the
middle trying to work out exactly what
we think but um one of the things we've
talked a little bit about already is
wokeness and apparently we keep being
told that this is a very hard thing to
Define in fact no one who criticizes can
Define that at all do you have a
definition of it that that you use yeah
I mean I have there's there's a lot of
different definitions because it takes
so many different forms for me it's kind
of this proclivity to use superficial
identity markers to make a statement
about oneself and and their
individuality and then to
tribalistically sort of group these
people within these identity markers and
categorize them in a hierarchical system
if you look back at early Marxism it was
a sort of Distinction was made by by
class and how much money and wealth you
had and now with wokism it's these
identity markers that you can sort of
Stack to become a person of higher
Social Status and and oppression has
become currency in that way under this
system
that makes complete sense but I I put it
to to you Amala because this is a
question that I struggle with can you
not be against that and still be on the
left
you know I I think you can and that's
why we're seeing a lot of people right
now who are identifying as heterodox or
politically homeless and I'm currently
on that Journey myself of walking around
and hearing all these political labels
and then getting a million definitions
for what they mean and sometimes people
will talk to me and say oh well you've
identified as conservative that means
this this and that and now I'm in a
space where I'm saying okay just ask me
on an issue by issue basis I'll tell you
how I feel about that certain issue and
that's how we should all be as as
individuals I think the labels have
really harmed us but we are patterned
human beings and that's what we like to
go by and that's what we use I think you
can certainly be a left-leaning or
liberal person without subscribing
yourself to to wokeism
and coming back to something you said
earlier in terms of the ability to
persuade people that's something we
think about a lot on this show because
uh ultimately I think that it will be
the answer particularly with young
people who uh in your case it doesn't
sound like you'd been exposed to a
different world view prior to actually
having the experience of being
confronted with what some of the views
that you held meant in practice and in
reality right but it also doesn't sound
to me like you were persuaded by anyone
you were persuaded by experience so is
it actually possible in your opinion to
persuade people to a different point of
view by talking to them
I I do think it's possible for me it was
a combination of things I had these
unanswered questions and these deep
feelings that I just couldn't quite
place and as a young person I turned to
the Internet so I started going online
not to find different opinions but to
reinforce my beliefs and to sort of find
the statistics that support my ideas
about police brutality and systemic
racism and then I stumbled upon people
who were content creators uh with a
conservative mindset or just looking for
uh the the objective truths in regard to
these matters so I ran into Tom soul and
Larry Elder and Dave Rubin and all these
people who were having these discussions
and once you start watching these videos
you just fall down a rabbit hole and for
me I I just fell down that rabbit hole
of people talking to me through a screen
and that was how I woke up but when I go
to universities and meet with young
people who were just like I was say four
years ago and have a lot of vitriol and
hatred towards people who disagree with
them the most success that I've had is
in telling my story of being a former
leftist and kind of looking at them and
saying you know four years ago I would
have been the one who organized the
protests that you all are here for right
now and now I just want to have a
conversation with you and I don't want
any gotcha moments I'm not trying to
come at you and make you feel stupid or
brainwashed and it's had a low success
rate in that maybe five out of the 50
students that are protesting me come
into the speech but I think five is
better than zero and it's better than a
lot of of conservative pundits at least
at the time are getting
I see the way sometimes and maybe we've
been guilty of this or maybe I've been
guilty of this you know the way that we
talk about your generation and a lot of
the time it's not particularly
complementary and and whatever else
and analyzingly now I think that's
actually quite unfair why do you think
it is that so many of your peers ascribe
to this ideology I would have loved it
if you'd ask you why do you think it is
so many of your peers or a woke
snowflake idiot
I was going to interrupt you and say you
know a lot of the criticism is rightful
our generation is pretty messed up
experience and
why I think that's just youthfulness at
its core is wanting to be transformative
wanting to be rebellious and
a little bit of cynicism I think is
mixed in in youth as well and I think
with that you have this perfect cocktail
for wanting to be a leftist we are
searching for value or searching for a
fight at least I certainly was at that
age and
it was served to me on a silver platter
not only do you have something to fight
but it's given to you by virtue of being
born the way that you're born so here is
the fight here's what you have to do and
the only way that you get through this
is by going out and convincing other
people to be activists towards this
cause so it's extremely enticing and
then you couple that with a group of
people who also wants to give you
everything we want you to have a free
school we want you to have Universal
basic income we want to sort of even out
the economy and make sure that there's
no poverty and everybody's doing well
and everybody's educated and all of
these things sound wonderful plus they
give you a fight to fight so I think
that's why young people love leftism
conservatism or even going through and
trying to find objective truths is a lot
harder to do and it's a lot less fun
it's definitely not as cool to hear that
you don't have as many problems and you
don't have sort of a crutch to stand on
for for where you're at in life
but also I mean if you look at the
history of the United States it's not
great like a lot of histories or
actually every history of every country
there's been inequality that's been
racism so isn't there a kernel of Truth
to these people's arguments
yes so I talk a lot about where woke
ideas come from and how they sort of
become courses essentially at college
that you can now take and a lot of
people will say well how dare how could
you be against critical race Theory
they're teaching at a Yale they're
teaching it at Harvard things like that
and it's because these ideas start with
a very strong moral impulse I think a
lot of people who are anti-woke get one
thing in particular wrong and it's that
these people sort of lack a strong sense
of morality or that they are inherently
immoral that's not the case at all in
fact they're very strongly driven by
their their moral impulses and when you
look at America's history and the
transgressions that have been committed
a lot of people have moral impulses
towards those things and they go
absolutely that is a horrible thing that
should have never happened and of course
we need to take some form of reparative
measures and that's what woke leftists
think they're doing now the only issue
is they tend to skew to the most radical
form term of a prescription that you
could possibly give to a problem like
racism or or sexism instead of saying
this thing is wrong and we should call
out people when they do it and there
should maybe be social repercussions for
somebody who is racist or sexist they
skew all the way over to the left and
say well if you are white you are
inherently racist if you are a man you
are inherently sexist and we learn this
throughout our history so they use the
kernels of Truth to make a much broader
claim that people fall for
and what are these kernels of Truth
Pamela yeah I mean we we went through
quite a long history of slavery in this
country and and after uh freeing the
enslaved we went through a Jim Crow era
where we still could not manage to
legally prescribe a quality to our
society we went through a period of time
where women couldn't vote uh they were
not enticed to get educations or or have
jobs there are certain disparities among
People based on their race their age
their size all of these things exist and
should be discussed and talked about uh
and it's funny we we fight on the the
prescription for how we solve these
things but we also fight on whether or
not we're willing to acknowledge and I
think everybody should acknowledge that
these transgressions have existed
throughout our history it's not it's not
a wrong thing to say in fact
acknowledging the transgressions should
be a fulfilling thing because we also
acknowledge the progress that we've made
out of them
hey Constantine do you like being
healthy of course in my country we judge
Men's Health by his ability to wrestle
bear turns out in London Russell bear
has very different meaning
we've already knocked the scored out of
hand
[Applause]
we will speak no more of this the secret
will be buried with my ancestors well if
you want to stay healthy and not feel
like you need to be buried with
Constantine's ancestors then you need to
try ag1 ag1 a simple and easy way to get
all new trends you need each serving
contains 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients one scoop and you feel like
real men we use it on our America Tour
where we were constantly on the Move
living out of a bag and working every
day ag1 meant we felt great look great
and we avoided getting sick one scoop a
day meant we knew we had all the
vitamins and minerals needed for the day
we had hugely successful trip it is very
economical and I felt strong enough to
wrestle American bird which we all know
is grotesly weak compared to Great
Russian verb if you're looking for a
simpler and cost effective supplement
routine ag1 is give way free one-year
supply of vitamin D and five travel
packs with your first purchase go to
athleticgreens.com
trigonometry that's athleticrings.com
trigonometry check it out and become
real men like me
you know what's weird to me Amala uh I I
wasn't born here in the UK I'm from
Russia originally I don't know what your
family background as I imagine you were
born in the US but but you probably know
that the things that you were talking
about not not in an identical way but
they happened in in every country I mean
uh I I talk about it in my books slavery
was pretty common everywhere uh and
actually the British Empire was was the
first to end it as opposed to being the
worst of the culprits and so on so do
you have any insight into why our
Societies in particular have become so
self-flagellating and uh instead of
looking at those things that we've just
discussed in a in a kind of well that's
history thank God we're not there
anymore let's be grateful approach which
is my view of it really we sort of go no
no we're all terrible and we must beat
ourselves up endlessly about it
yeah I I wish I knew why our society in
particular chose to take that route I I
would like to say maybe it's we we've
become so comfortable and we we don't
have as many problems here that we are
now trying to find them and we've looked
to history to do that but there's a lot
of other countries who are uh just as
comfortable as we are here in the U.S I
think our academic structures may be
different than the other countries and a
lot of these ideas when you trace them
back to their roots or going back to the
60s and 70s where you know you you
essentially had college students writing
theories and and uh
writing theories about these ideas like
of critical race Theory or or critical
feminism and then these journals are
published and reviewed and published and
reviewed and eventually they become
tenured professors and they're teaching
classes like that and I think maybe our
structure in Academia or our system here
has given way to these issues but I I
can't really pin down why America has so
much guilt towards its history in other
countries don't no you you you
identified a couple of very good points
one has come for the other the
indoctrination in school you put those
two together uh you're gonna get some
pretty powerful results
yeah I I when I was first going through
this journey of finding people who whose
ideas really resonated with me I found a
man by the name of Yuri besmanov which
I'm sure you're probably both familiar
with and he did several speeches on
ideological subversion and how it starts
with education and his videos if the
people listening have not seen them uh
please go and watch them because they
think there's no better description of
what is happening right now and he
claims that it starts in education so
maybe maybe that's the root cause
Amala do you think as well it's social
media especially when you look at during
the pandemic what happened when we're
all effectively locked in our homes and
we Mainline social media and into our
eyeballs for 18 hours a day no wonder
that social justice and all these
organizations Rose to prominence
yeah it is it's crazy how bad you will
think the world is if you're on social
media it's unbelievable I'm of the
opinion that we should not be as hooked
into news as we are it's sort of
unbelievable if we break down on a scale
how many sad happy it doesn't even
matter uh the the sort of emotion behind
the stories but how many stories we are
hearing on a daily basis how often we
are looking at other people's faces on a
daily basis how often we are seeing our
own faces mirrored back to us on a daily
basis I don't think any of this is
particularly helpful or healthy for the
human mind and social media I mean we
we've studied and researched as far as
we know now because it's a relatively
new thing on the human brain is
deteriorating young minds in particular
you have not only this influx of stories
that you're hearing all the time which
can make you think the world is a lot
worse than it actually is but you also
have pairing your life to to other lives
and young women in particular are really
susceptible to developing mental health
issues due to that and social media is
also working on a cycle of
glamorizing fetishizing oppression
mental health problems and you're you go
farther on social media the more unique
you are and it's unfortunate that not
everybody can be the most unique person
in the world but we can all try to
emulate and uh sort of absorb the things
that we're seeing on social media and
unfortunately I think we're absorbing
some of the worst bits of what's on the
internet
and anecdotally looking at your own
generation
in particular women what have you seen
oof I mean with with young women on the
internet I think it's it's really
changed everything the internet used to
be at least social media in particular
used to be a sort of highlight reel of
your life and everybody for the most
part knew it was fake yeah you're not on
the beach every day you just took 50
photos and now you're posting them and
and you're not really living this
glamorous life and you and your
boyfriend are so in love but I saw you
guys fighting last weekend at the
football game stuff like that but now
social media is just how many pieces of
myself can I put on the internet and
we're sort of mining all the bits of us
that we feel we can commercialize to
other people and
young women when they're going through
just their formative years I went
through it being exposed to social media
can just fry your brain you're seeing
people who look nothing like you who are
getting all of this attention you see uh
just basically an algorithm that's
telling you what is valuable and just
how valuable it is and you start
applying yourself to your own social
media accounts and seeing what bits of
you people take to and what bits of you
people don't and essentially you're
creating metrics for your personality
and who you are as an individual and
young women right now are struggling way
more than they ever have with suicidal
ideation with different Mental Health
site uh comorbidities and
I struggle to think that that social
media is not a deeply set part of that
problem
yeah
particularly when we look at young women
and what's happened to them it always
shocks me when I see women of your age
Amela and they've got Botox why have you
got Botox why have you got lip fillers
you are in the flush of Youth the last
thing you need is to freeze parts of
your face so you don't get wrinkles that
to me it strikes me as awful yeah it's
it's crazy and I live in LA so it's like
every woman every woman is it's it's
just so normal I'm like oh what are you
doing this Saturday oh you know I'm
going to get BOTOX or I'm going to get
filler and there's a long line of girls
all doing the same and they're all in
their early 20s and we've just it's
grown so normal when you go on social
media and you see people who are using
face filters or their Instagram models
and they've gotten all this work done
you think oh well why should I do the
same and in fact it's greatly encouraged
I can't tell you how many videos that I
see of women saying if you need a sign
to go get BOTOX Here's your sign to to
do it today look at my face it's so
beautiful and
it sucks that women are so obsessed with
aging and something that's going to
happen naturally and it sucks that we
cannot take on Aging as something that
is beautiful and something that should
be celebrated we're celebrated
celebrating all the wrong things and in
fact reinforcing what feminists claim to
be against is this idea that beauty is
something that needs to be uh held on to
or beauty is something that you cannot
keep if you if you age naturally and
it's just so so harmful and I can't
imagine having a young daughter in this
day and age who was looking up and
seeing all of these standards that
they're somehow supposed to meet
naturally but can can never do that
and do you think that's part of the
reason as well that you kind of drifted
to the right when you look at the things
that are being espoused by society and a
lot of the time but also by people on
the left you know that you can be
whatever you want you can change your
gender you can change this you can
change that
and the reality is is they're denying
biology they're denying human nature and
then it's a denial of nature itself
yes the denial of Truth was a big mover
for me in in changing my my viewpoint on
a lot of different subjects and it's
also the fact that
there's so much hypocrisy in that
statement of you can be whoever you want
to be when you really get down to the
root of how they are implementing this
in their own lives if you look into
leftism and you look into it deeply and
especially identity politics you will
find that there is no space to be
whoever it is that you want to be there
is no space to think whatever it is that
you want to think and in fact they are
hell-bent on pushing people into boxes I
felt no greater racism than going on the
internet and saying I am a conservative
it was unbelievable how quickly people
jumped to me and said well you're a
female You couldn't possibly be
conservative you're half black You
couldn't possibly be conservative this
is the box that is created for those
identity markers and we must Jam you
into that box and if you do not fit you
are alienated you are no longer a part
of the club so as much as they say
everybody's special and unique and they
can be whoever they want to be they
don't think that at all and they think
there's no greater
I guess social experiment to prove that
that is the case then what's happening
right now with gender if you look at
somebody like Dylan Mulvaney who came up
in that Matt Walsh video who we've both
been talking about quite a bit Dylan
Mulvaney is a feminine man
it's as simple and plain as that but
because he's expressed himself femininly
they say well you must now shove
yourself into the box that is Womanhood
and we must now claim you as a woman we
must call you she and her and this is
the box that you now fit in I'm pretty
sure you're telling this boy happy to be
shoved in that box I think Dylan is
desperate to get in that box he really
is I think he's proven that time and
time again but the the issue still
stands there's no no I get who you are
of course no I get your point completely
and
um you know it's the denial the whole I
mean if you're if you're a fan of Thomas
old the whole idea of nature he's
written extensively about how the left
and the right see that very differently
um and I'm curious with you living in La
do you have any friends
I do
I have managed to find friends uh I've
I've got some some brilliant friends
some of whom I've met through prageru
others who I've met just through moving
to the city met my boyfriend here in La
somehow I just think I've been I've been
very lucky
no it's funny the reason I ask is a very
good friend of ours called Bridge of
fantasy who you probably have heard of
yeah
um when we traveled around America last
year we did a whole trip and we went to
uh we went to Virginia and Washington
and New York in a bunch of places and
everywhere we went there's gigantic
American flags all over the place loads
of houses have them outside and then we
got to Bridget's house and she had this
like tiny little American flag in the
corner of a little bit of a door and I
went that's California patriotism you
have a flag but it is about this big in
a corner because you can't you can't
have the big one no yeah you're 100
right most of the people who I meet who
watch my content here in La I I can see
them because they kind of walk up to me
and they whisper but they that they like
what I have to say or that they follow
me on Instagram you can't say anything
too loud you have a lot of quiet friends
here in Los Angeles
but surely Amela is going to come to a
point with like we're we're in San
Francisco where you look around and you
go
this can't carry on this is this is
insanity
I like to think that's gonna happen I I
don't know I really don't know it's
crazy to watch as things just
deteriorate and people I don't know if
they're not making the connection
between what they're voting for and
what's happening in their city or if
they just simply cannot bring themselves
to you know tick The Ballot Box of
somebody who they they feel they
fundamentally disagree with I don't know
that it's going to change and all the
conversations that I have with people
who are supporting the stuff that's
happening in La it's kind of like they
just turn a blind eye to to the
destruction and
you would think like Yuri besmanov says
you you don't really recognize it until
the military boot kicks you in the ass
the military boot is kicking them in the
ass here and they're not making the
connection I I don't know I don't know
how long you you should be the person
who has the answer to this because I
guess the question would be four years
ago if someone said to you look around
you know there's drug drug addicts who
are not getting the help they need
sleeping on the streets being sexually
assaulted spreading disease to each
other and the rest of the pop like all
of that yeah surely I'm only you're
against that as a woke activist surely
you want those people to be better right
so so what would your answer have been
I think I would have found a way to
blame it on the people who I disagree
with
I would have managed I really think I
would have managed I was really good at
just running my mouth and twisting words
and I think that's exactly what I
probably would have spun it and said you
know the income disparities created by
conservatives and we need to tax the
rich and and that's what's going to help
these people who are impoverished and
who are you know doing drugs on the
street I would have found a way knowing
myself
but you know it kind like I said there's
there's got to be a point because there
are a couple of days ago Guy Pearce came
out the famous Hollywood act too
actually I'm a massive fan of I love his
work and it's fun and he came out and
went look you know shouldn't actors be
able to play all different types of
roles and shouldn't a non-trans out to
be able to play a trans role I didn't
even say that actually what he said was
even more gentle what he said is if
transactors have to if you have to play
a trans if a trans role has to be played
by a transactor then uh is it then
restricting what roles trans actors can
play so he was formally at least looking
out for the transact as he wasn't saying
shouldn't we all be able to he wasn't
even that brave
and and then and then obviously you know
the the you know the the might of all
the all the people who came out and were
just saying is this is that he's
whatever else and he had to make a
groveling apology as they all do but you
look at it and again you go
this surely even an opinion as
reasonable as this one which is shared
by I would say probably 98 of the
population
and it's deemed to be incorrect this
isn't sustainable
it's not it's certainly not sustainable
and I don't know exactly how it falls
apart I think a lot of it is going to be
with
sort of exactly what you just described
them eating each other alive because uh
with you know liberal people censor
people right-leaning people for the most
part there's room there's a quite a bit
of room for for disagreement within
their respective camps with wokism there
isn't and that was where I felt a lot of
pressure myself and felt pushed away by
them to answer the questions that I had
because I wouldn't maybe raise my hand
and go oh wait a second you know maybe
open borders doesn't sound like the best
solution to the problems we're talking
about here and you are chastised to hell
I mean it's it's crazy to to even the
the amount of pressure you feel to
completely be subservient to everything
that they say and to toe the line uh and
I can imagine that that pressure
can be a lot and it's a big weight for a
lot of people who would self-describe as
woke leftists and I think it has to be
personal for you to change your mind and
often that personal experience that
people have is being canceled or feeling
that pressure of having a dissident
opinion and maybe not being able to
verbalize it or when you verbalize it
going through the attacks that you feel
so I think that is part of how this this
falls apart but it's also going to fall
apart in just the chaos that we're
experiencing in cities it's unfortunate
that that doesn't happen uh however
until it hits the backyard of of
legislators in San Francisco we saw
mayor London breed go you know the crime
has gotten too crazy and we need to do
something about it and we need to
reinforce our police officers when she
was one of the the main pushers of the
deep on the police but it wasn't until
the crime hit her her side of town that
she had to say something about it and
that's the unfortunate part of all of
this you have to feel the failing
yes and another unfortunate part of it
is how racist it all is it's not you see
white liberals and they're not liberals
but let's just call them what they I
would identify as yeah
how racial episodes
are ethnic minorities for disagreeing
with them and you go I mean this isn't
right is it and everyone's like no this
is what we do now and you go well I
don't know if I'm on board with this
yeah the so I I said before the most
racism I've ever experienced was after
coming out as a conservative and I
cannot
I cannot press that enough so I grew up
in a really small rural conservative
Town it was surrounded by uh mainly
white people was subscribed completely
to this idea of racism and white people
being inherently racist but had never
experienced an out an ounce of it I come
out as a conservative and suddenly every
single piece of racist rhetoric that is
typically uh scribe to conservatives was
hurled at me I mean I was called a house
negro I was told that I would always be
seen as an n-word no matter what I did I
was told that I was an Uncle Tom a [__]
and of course this is the same
experience of Larry Elder of Tom Soule
of Candace Owens of anybody who chooses
to come out and say these things if you
want to really experience or get as
close to the Jim Crow experience as
possible be a black person that comes
out as a conservative and it will you
will you will experience it
can I ask you something about like your
earlier years because you mentioned
growing up in a in a mostly white small
conservative town uh you said you're
raised by the white side of your family
right yes so your your mother is white
she's raising you she had sex with a
black guy yeah like how how are you then
able in that situation to think that you
know all white people are inherently
racist when you've got a white mum who
who who got together with a black guy
and who's raising a mixed race daughter
presumably she wasn't calling you the N
word in your crib right right right no
my mom never called me the N word
um so yeah my mom of course is uh she's
a white Ally but it's interesting when I
when I was working with all of these
white people including my mother at this
organization they feel so much white
guilt that they then themselves feel
there is no way to sort of separate
themselves from from the history of
white people and although it might not
uh take
take form as blatant racism towards
black people they may have black friends
they may marry a black person and half
biracial kids they still recognize
things like unconscious bias or say you
know that they can still be fall victim
to prejudice against people of color or
maybe have some internalized ideas
towards people of color so there's
always just a little kernel still left
there to be able to push the narrative
that white people are inherently racist
well what about you like you've got a
white mum and you believe that all white
people learn how so your mum is
inherently racist yeah I mean I I can
tell you I didn't look into these ideas
too deeply
which is why they fell apart whenever I
was pressed on them I what is so
enticing about leftism is not only that
you don't have to look into the idea so
deeply but also you are safeguarded in
somewhat of a cultish manner that you
have no obligation to defend those ideas
and that in fact the the very Act of
trying to challenge somebody on those
beliefs is inactive racism is inactive
sexism so all I had to do was when
people were asking me questions about
this go oh you're racist just for asking
me that your sex is just for asking that
question and you're encouraged to make
those accusations and to not talk to
people who you disagree with
yeah
um you've talked and you've mentioned
the fact that you're a conservative
what does conservatism mean to you
because the thing is with all these
labels they actually mean something very
different to different people like
someone will say I'm conservative and
you know what you ask a conservative in
this country the chances are they're
pro-gay marriage and their anti-gun now
if you do that in the United States that
kind of means you're a Democrat
yeah it's interesting and I I sort of
came out of the gate when I had this
transformation and went okay well
I actually fell for the same problem
that I had when I was a leftist where I
said well if I'm not a leftist then I
must be a conservative and I sort of
went really hard uh on on that and said
well if these people are wrong and these
people must be right and now I'm sort of
floating in this space of okay do I I
identify as conservative or am am I just
right leaning on an issue by issue basis
and I'm totally honest in saying that
that's something that I'm still
exploring I mean for the most part I am
anti-feminist as far as modern day
feminism is concerned I am pro-gon and
pro Second Amendment I am pro-gay
marriage so that's a point for uh for
the left-leaning end of things and I'm
just going through all these issues and
I guess why I said right of Center at
the beginning is that I feel I'm
socially and fiscally to to the right
when it comes to American politics
okay and what does that mean let's dig a
Little Deeper what does that mean
socially and fiscal yeah so so socially
I guess it means rejecting a lot of the
woke narratives and the identity of
politics I don't prescribe myself to the
idea of Oppression in this country
socially I Am pro Second Amendment which
is a strong issue I happen to be
pro-life with some exceptions
uh when it comes to abortion which is a
recent topic uh socially with feminism
I'm very much against all of the the
rhetoric there I'm trying to think what
other what other common social issues
are we going back and forth with
uh you know what's interesting other
than the gun thing which is obviously a
big divider in your country all of those
things until about three minutes ago
would have put you bang in the middle of
politics in America and in the UK
actually you know what I mean imagine
you want people to be supported but you
don't want a massive welfare state I
imagine that you believe that women
should have rights but you're not you
don't think air conditioning is sex it's
like these are all things sure like I
said until about two minutes ago most
people believe they were not and and
that's one of the things that I kind of
see happen is I don't know that
people like you and people like us that
are being pushed away from where they
started which would have been on the
left unnecessarily all that conservative
or right-wing in the first place I just
think we're not woke and I think what's
what we're trying to find out is like
what does that what's the space that
that creates that has a more positive
orientation towards the future
I I'm trying to figure that out as well
I've been thinking a lot and mulling
over just not going by anything anymore
and just going around and talking about
the issues as they come the current
events as they come because in in many
ways I think in in being anti-woke I did
at some point get pigeonholed into
conservatism and sometimes you'll say
things and I'm sure you get this as well
where maybe conservatives will follow
you because you have your certain stance
on gender and then you say something
else and it's like the roof is blown off
because you're not fully subscripted to
every week yeah everything's every week
so that that's an issue that I've got
I've gone through I can related Dave
Rubin on having children uh through
surrogacy and that was like how dare you
call yourself a conservative and this
happens so I honestly I think going to
move to just an anti-anti-label future
and just let people deal with it it's
crazy to me because I'm I'm a big
supporter and fan of Russell Brand and I
watch all the videos that he puts out
he's now called a far-right extremist
and
I I just cannot fathom how anybody would
make that characterization for him so I
think exactly what you said Is Right
yeah I suppose it's a challenge for you
if I can say so it might be that you
have locked yourself into a Prager you
which is a conservative organization
nothing wrong with that but but you are
kind of attached aren't you
yeah I mean I think
I am free to express all the things that
I've expressed today are the same things
that I express on on my show I think
they just happen to have that
conservative label on their organization
I feel for the most part uh with what
preview puts out it very much resonates
with me so I don't know that I've been
necessarily stuck with with the label
itself or that people
see that from me for the most part when
I'm meeting people or talking to people
I made a really wide range of different
ideological backgrounds and leanings and
people just know me for for who I am I I
don't think the label has to be has to
be stuck yeah yeah that's really
interesting and I and I do think that's
the problem now is that labels don't
mean anything but you were talking and
you're making criticisms about leftism
and if you would explain to somebody 15
years ago that's what left and left him
to me and said look at you like you've
been dropped on your head yeah I think a
woman is a woman yeah you'd be like
right yeah like I said they've
completely switched I mean leftism if
you look it back on what it was maybe
the 1970s I was like oh yeah Pro
skepticism uh anti-establishment you
know you you are skeptical of government
entities and you probably don't want it
to grow beyond the point that it's at
now oh yeah that sounds like a leftist
to me I I think I'd be able to to get
behind that but it's just shifted and
morphed and I think as they pull farther
left the the people anybody who's on the
other end is going to pull farther to
the other side and that's where they're
actually going to run into some issues
because they can't imagine what a right
leaning equivalent would look like to
some of the stuff that they're managing
to pull off today and I don't want to
see that quite frankly do you think
America needs more political parties
Amala so actually so the people
go on tell me what big question I I
don't know that it needs ah it's so
weird because I don't know that it needs
more political parties or just no
political parties I don't know how how I
would go about doing this are our
founding fathers directly warned against
the creation of political parties George
Washington in particular and said and
basically prophecy that it was going to
lead to these tribalistic issues and it
essentially just becomes you know cogs
in a wheel that are just stuck and
they're they're never going to move
anywhere which is where we're at right
now and
where our conversation comes about
defining leftism defining liberalism
defining conservative these are major
problems because most of people sit in
the middle on any particular given issue
but now we're in this sort of split case
of left versus right or democrat versus
Republican and people feel the need to
go for the side that best represents how
they feel on what 10 different issues so
I don't know if I'm just anti-all
political parties like our our founding
fathers were I guess in the system that
we're in now the necessity would be to
create more because I don't think
there's any way that we are going to
break down uh the the two-party system
that we're in right now and there's no
better example of an issue on which
actually there is that level of
polarization and a complete lack of
consensus than the Second Amendment and
guns which you you brought up and
obviously there was this terrible
shooting recently
um and this is uh By the way when we're
America we went to the gun range and
shot some guns we went to a big gun show
I always said I I'm happy to live in
Britain where we don't have private
ownership of handguns other than for
hunting but uh if I lived in America
most places in America I probably
wouldn't have a gun in central New York
I don't think I'd be allowed but most
places I I I'd haven't trained with
Firearms Etc however I have to say it's
from a British perspective we look at
you guys and we go that's crazy like
what's going on in America is insane
right and I the reason we think that is
because in this country in the late 90s
I think it was we had a one school
shooting in in a place called dunblane
in Scotland
and after that everyone
uh let's not have guns anymore
we didn't we haven't had a mass shooting
since in the school right so to us I'm
not saying it applies to America I'm not
saying it should apply to America but
from from a British perspective
generally it's like this kind of seems
like a solvable problem so tell us why
it's it's not
yeah so my boyfriend's from Sydney
Australia so he sees the same thing that
you see English just like what the [__]
is going on and why are you guys
allowing this to happen here it should
not be the case uh and I'm certainly
sympathetic to that view and I think a
lot of people here in America are it
very deeply goes back to the foundation
of this country and I think uh with the
Second Amendment and the fact that this
country began with an uprising towards
what they deemed to be a tyrannical
totalitarian government people are
worried about that ever happening again
and they think that the Second Amendment
is pivotal in protecting themselves from
that possibility in the future and
in America since we are so Pro
individualism and So Pro Freedom the the
freedom to protect oneself is something
that so many people hold near and dear
to to their hearts so we are dealing
with the polarization of those that
would be happy to to give that up and
those who think that it's both
fundamental to the founding of this
country and a right that they should
have as an individual to protect
themselves so I don't know
that the gun issue
is ever going to get solved I think it's
going to get stricter and stricter and
stricter uh but I I don't know that
we're ever going to go back on on the
Second Amendment no no I don't imagine
you will and actually the argument you
gave which is which is
um resisting government tyranny I think
is the strongest argument actually in
favor of gun ownership
I I don't necessarily think that that
means it is a strong argument and the
reason I say that is you look at what
happened during covid right people were
locked in their homes and a lot of
people were against that they were were
they did they go out and and fight for
their rights
yeah I I think they're in in a sense
awaiting or or using that example to be
more of a when the when the rubber meets
the road I don't know that it would be
some sort of Revolution or Uprising but
when when the government again I promise
you we're not going to do it we have we
haven't got the army or the balls we're
worried about you guys anymore
yeah I know what you mean and it's it's
a difficult issue but I think I think
you make the point
you make the right point which is on a
practical level given the number of
people that have to agree to to amend
the Constitution it's just not it's not
a whether people whatever the Rights and
Wrongs of what are it's just not going
to happen right right and it's I mean
economically the government has no
incentive to do something like that and
I think uh just the amount of you know
the common argument the the bad men with
the guns who uh are running rampant in
specifically or metropolitan areas
people want to protect themselves and
for the most part uh law-abiding gun
owners are
not necessarily the problem I don't know
about the case of this Nashville shooter
because I don't know that uh that what's
come out there I certainly think with
issues of mental illness and people
being assessed as a harm to themselves
or a harm to others there certainly
needs to be stricter laws I am certainly
for stricter laws as far as is gun
control is concerned and I don't think
we should be in this frivolous Society
where you could just go anywhere and get
anything at any given moment
does it worry you Amela the the
divisions in your country the fact that
everyone has to pick a team the fact
that everyone has to pick a side when
the reality is most people don't care
that much about politics and nor should
they because as we all know there are
far more important things in life why
are we being forced to pick a team
continually
why are we being forced to pick a team
continually it's tough because where
politics doesn't matter on a day-to-day
basis it is starting to affect people's
daily lives a lot more the reason that
we're talking about these gender issues
is because now we got like kids talking
about sex and sexuality in school and
developing mental health issues or
trying to transition so in in the grand
scheme I think a lot of people think oh
well politics doesn't matter all that
much but
politics and culture are great movers
for social change and change in our
daily Lifestyles so I think that's why
people are polarized and and asked to
choose am I frightened a little bit
about the amount of division a little a
little bit sometimes I'm going to give
out speeches and I think okay what does
security look like at this event and
what's going to happen and uh somebody
needs to keep an eye on things so
nobody should feel like that in in doing
the work that we do and it seems as
though everybody does so
I'm certainly concerned I don't know
what necessarily the solution is for
breaking down the tribalism though
well I think you're doing it actually
which is its honest inquiry being
prepared to change your mind being able
to see where people are coming from
trying to meet them where they're at and
being honest with yourself because I
think it's very very tempting as you
talked about the moment you realize that
you are not you don't fit in the
environment in which you we found the
same thing we were two comedians in an
extremely woke comedy industry from
which unlike United States There's No
Escape there's one industry and if you
if you full file of that there's nowhere
for you to go unless you want to go to
to another country right and once that
happens it's very tempting as you say to
go to the other side and be like oh
these guys have all the answers but when
you go there you find out they're really
really don't and so I think honest
inquiry of the type that you are engaged
in and we try to engage in is the way to
go uh listen it's been an absolute
pleasure chatting with you uh we're
going to ask you a few questions from
our local supporters that only they will
get to see the answer to and they're
always brilliant but before we let you
go uh what is the one thing that we're
not talking about as a society that you
think will really should be
um
I think I'm gonna go with this I've been
mulling it over relationships are very
important familial friendships uh all of
these just deeply set relationships that
you can build in your life are really
important and people should be focusing
on that regardless of their political
ideology I get asked I get the most when
I'm doing interviews is how is the
relationship between you and your mom
now you're on two different sides of the
spectrum how is this working and I tell
people we are closer than we've ever
been because we've decided that that is
not the most important part of our
relationship and so many people now I
think feel lonely where they're at and
that's also what is pushing forward this
political divide it's it's social media
it's a lack of relationships it's a lack
of human interaction and deep human
interaction so prioritize that as much
as you prioritize your job and your
political fights and all these different
things and you'll find that your life is
just so much better and so much happier
so that's what I want people to to talk
about and think about
awesome well Amela before we head over
to local just tell everybody uh where to
find you on the internet uh you know all
the social media and of course you're
Unapologetic uh with amla on YouTube
here as well yeah sure so you can find
me anywhere on any platform by searching
amola epinobi I know it's a mouthful but
you will find me at the end of it and uh
yeah I'm everywhere and active all the
time
I'm an economy thank you so much for
coming on the show it's been an absolute
pleasure thank you for watching and for
those of you who've been enjoying the
show always remember that it goes out
Wednesdays and Sundays 7 P.M UK time and
for those of you like you and those of
you who like your trigonometry on the go
it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
what was the craziest thing that you
believed when you were uh still woke
[Music]
foreign